joined by the chair of the education
select committee and rishi sunac
supporter that's robert halfon hello to
mr health and thanks for joining us on
the programme we've been hearing from
energy companies over the last 24 hours
they want this leadership contest to end
and the new prime minister to con uh con
um concentrate i should say on what is
happening as far as the cost of living
crisis is concerned why doesn't your guy
just throw his hat into the uh
honestly i can't even speak this morning
i don't know what's going give up
basically throw the towel in that's the
phrase i was looking for
well the contest is is not over until
it's over there's only a less than a
couple of weeks to go before a new prime
minister
is appointed they've been different
polls the polls of conservative
councillors have had wishy sunak and liz
trust level plaguing i think he's got an
important program for the country i'm
supporting him because i think he's
trusted when times were tough and we saw
that with the furlough scheme i think
that he's done a lot on the cost of
living providing
1200 pounds up to 1200 pounds for 8
million of the most vulnerable
families and i also support him because
of what he's saying on education about
having a british pclaudia more support
for vocational and technical education
and more free schools
it may well be the case but by any
measure he's miles behind in the contest
and we have a cost of living crisis
where inflation could be up to 18 by
january it's all over for him he just
needs to accept that
i think that members have a right to
have a choice of who they would like to
have as prime minister and they've
chosen liz trust it would appear there's
voting over yet there's some many many
members who haven't yet uh voted when
she goes around the country has a lot of
support i mentioned the poll of
conservative councillors which showed
both candidates level playing it's still
all too uh playful be over very uh
shortly but you're absolutely right um
that cost of living is the number one
concern for
the nation and that's again why i'm
supporting rishi sunat because he says
we've got to cut inflation which is the
enemy of uh the cost of living we've got
to cut our national debt because if the
government faces a triple whammy of
public spending pressures national uh
debt and uh helping with the cost of
living you've got to deal with those
things first before you can have
significant tax cuts yeah and to do that
you need to be prime minister and the
big beast sajid uh javid i'm looking at
my list penny mordant ben wallace nadeem
zaharwee brandel lewis quasi quatting to
raise coffee they're all supporting the
other candidate
well big beasts like william hague
um nigel lawson
are in the cabinet
ranch chaps is in the cabinet stephen
bark is in the cabinet mark spencer is
in the uh cabinet but this is not just
about a level celebrities um or sorry a
celebrities who are you know who support
the
various leadership candidates about the
programme for uh the country and
i believe that wishy sunak has a
responsible program
in cutting the cost of living dealing
with the debt cutting inflation then
having a program towards uh income tax
cuts and and we will need major
interventions on the cost of living we
can't have
significant
tax cuts yet because of the pressures on
the public purse
if he cared
as you say about um the poorest in our
society he would acknowledge that the
race is over and fall in behind liz
truss who by any measure is miles ahead
in the polls um and accept that he's
lost
i think it's right that the members have
a choice and i think wichita has shown
that he cares about the most
vulnerable he spent 37 billion pounds
when he was just chancellor just a few
months ago trying to help people get
through the cost of living a 400 pound
rebate for everyone on their energy
bills 1200 pounds for 8 million of the
most vulnerable families 150 pound
rebate in council tax most people a
national insurance tax cut in essence or
70 of households it's about what you do
and i think he is right um to be able to
have a chance uh to set his program not
just to the membership but to the the
country the contest will be over uh very
shortly i think it's right that members
have a choice it's still all to play for
haven't they had a choice so far
well the choice is that when
when when the membership votes and
they're voting at the moment not all the
members have voted there's still a
couple of weeks to go the candidates are
going around the country which is coming
to my own uh constituency uh in harlow
in a few in a few days meeting
members and that is the right thing to
do
um you are as i said chair of the
education select committee
what do you make of the report by the
tony blair institute for global change
calling for the scrapping of gcse and a
levels
well i believe for some time that we
need to look at gcsena levels but
particularly
a levels because we allow students to
narrow
at the age of 16 down to just three or
sometimes four
four subjects i've been to schools where
they teach what is called the
international victoria where they do a
wide variety of subjects and i think
that is a much better system
for the world we're entering the world
of automation the world of artificial
intelligence i do think we need much
more skills based education i'd like to
see more technical and vocational
education taught all the way through and
not have a dividing line between some
students doing vocational education and
some students doing academic it should
be a mixture of these of these things so
i think some things in the blair report
are well worth looking at but i should
note that rishi sunak we've been talking
about has also proposed a british
pclaudia uh from the age of 16 where
students would do a much wider variety
of subjects including maths and english
all the way through until they've they
finished this uh their school yeah and
if i'd done my a levels i would have
known the difference between throwing
your hat in the ring and throwing in the
towel it's good to talk to you this
morning thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the program much
appreciated thank you